A graphical version of the decision table is called a decision tree.
It's a form of a flow chart in which the decisions are taken sequentially and
the resulting output can be seen as a path through the tree.
It's exactly the same information as in the decision tree, but
you're seeing it in a different form.
In the decision tree we'll see in just a second, there are two kinds of nodes.
Diamonds denote decisions and rectangles denote the actions that are going to be
taken based upon the decisions that are made.
The arcs in the diagram indicate the implications when a decision is
answered in a particular way, either affirmatively or negatively.
Note that in the decision tree you're about to see,
some of the nodes have been duplicated.
This is a side effect of the redundancy which occurs in the table as well.
Here's the tree for the previous situation.
On the left is the decision about the master control and
the on, on the rightmost is the resultant
response from the system in terms of what lights are on and what lights are off.
Once again, same information is in the decision table.
Note that the two rightmost diamonds contain exactly the same question.
And that's it for combinatorial combinatorial logic.
As you can well imagine, as the number of possibilities for
the input goes up, these tables quickly become unmanage, unmanageable.